you look lovely thanks for being here
well thank you now you know you have uh
people are so thrilled uh with your work
in the help your role in that and then
you've got the debt coming out at the
same time and i thought you must have
been so busy doing these both and then i
found out today that the debt was shot a
few years ago is that right it's it's
kind of insane i've made 11 films in
four years right and the debt was made
two years ago and um my first film i
made four years ago with al pacino and
it's funny my poor mother every time i
make a film i'm like oh i'm in a movie
with al pacino or for the dad i'm in the
movie with helen mirren so she tells all
of her friends and then um
you know
they don't come out for a long time
so has the al pacino one come out yet
not yet so so here's the strange thing
you make this movie with alpacino then
you tell your friends i'm in a movie
with al pacino and then a couple of
years go by
and they think you're a liar i'm a total
liar my mom called me up finally and she
was like what are you doing in l.a
because it's not acting
what are you up to uh now you're you're
a very serious uh actress you're very
well trained graduate of juilliard yeah
right and uh what's the audition process
like for
for a school like juilliard i imagine
it's very rigorous
yes um i think i got some special
attention though because i did a romeo
and juliet monologue i did juliette
scallop a pace which i don't know if a
lot of people know but all right there
with you right
all the shakes for
um
and um you know the the monologue is
about a 14 year old girl saying hurry up
son go away
because then the night will be here and
i'll have sex
i'll be a woman yeah i mean shakespeare
wrote her a little differently a little
yeah i like your version's cool yeah
yeah but the language is super sexual
it's like come night come though
black brown night it's super like yes
right
so i gave it like it was your monologue
that you were to do yes and i was on the
ground
i'm like doing the monologue in front of
like the juilliard people
and it was like the scene from flash
dance when you see like you know you
know they're kind of like tapping their
fingers after a while and like bobbing
their heads they're really stuffy people
and i finished and i kind of like looked
up and they're just their faces were
just
shocked by me because you really went
for it is that right oh i went for it
like you're like writhing on the ground
i'm writhing my hands are in the air i'm
like saying give me my romeo
thank you
romeo's up here in the balcony
finally finally romeo is in a talk show
that's not how he finds juliet i went to
a taping of conan and for food
there she was
now is this right when you went to
juilliard i'm told your grandmother was
the one that drove you to juilliard and
she hung out a little bit she flew me
she flew you there yeah cause new york
yeah yeah um yeah she's she's a
wonderful lady my grandma she um has
always been the wild one in my family
your grandmother's the wild one she's
the wild wild one and um when we first
got to juilliard she's a smoker and i'm
i don't smoke or anything like that and
you can get kicked out it's serious
stuff for smoking in the dorm yeah we're
on the 26th floor and she doesn't want
to go downstairs but she really wants a
cigarette so she climbed on top of the
windowsill
and like the windows don't open all the
way because it's the 26th floor and
she's sticking her head like this and
trying to smoke quietly and i'm stuffing
towels under the door and like three
minutes in there's a knock the ras like
i smell smoke
so of course i'm saying it's not me it's
my grandma yeah which they don't really
well does she give you she sounds like
you said she's a character and she's
kind of wild what kind of career advice
does she give you does she ever give you
career advice oh well yes um you know it
starts with the stuff like what are you
wearing you know that kind of normal
grandma stuff does she want you to like
put on you know like
dress up cover yourself up no
no she wants the opposite she's my
grandma
she wants me to show like skin skin skin
skin and in fact you know when i've done
what your grandmother take it all off
you want to work again
you want to work in this town you'll
take it off sweetie
who is this woman well she's um you know
she had the nickname motorcycle mama
when i was in elementary school wow all
the kids in elementary school saw her
and called her motorcycle mama uh-huh
all right so yeah she's always been like
you know you need to be more sexual
jessica
what a cool grant